great to have back on the program jen
briny host of the congressional dish
podcast which exposes corporate
influence in the bills and laws passed
by congress Jen you've been following
the bombing by US forces in Libya I've
been following it the sort of public
line is we are working here we as the US
military to suppress and fight Isis
visit but as you've covered in a recent
episode of your program there's actually
a lot more to this isn't there there
definitely is um so one of the things
that I think is really important here is
that yes Isis has taken over the city of
cert and so that is why we're
theoretically going into Libya again and
bombing but the city of cert there were
about five to six thousand Isis members
at one point now there's a thousand and
so whatever the people in Libya were
doing was working and we're coming in at
the last minute in bombing so there's
definitely another story here it's also
important to know that we had the United
Nations invent another government in
Libya there's actually two governments
right now and we are acting as the
military for the United Nations invented
government the elected government of
Libya is right now the House of
Representatives who is refusing to
recognize the government of national
Accord the United Nations one as the
legal government of Libya so we're
getting involved in a civil war just
like we did in Syria and then we are
really the military of a government that
was imposed upon these people the Libyan
people have no say in anything that
we're doing and we continue to see this
sort of vicious cycle of American
foreign policy in certain parts of the
world where we're doing airstrikes
against Isis because prior military and
foreign policy decisions created a power
vacuum which led to the rise of Isis and
this is unlikely to be the last time
that we sort of observe this vicious
cycle we've seen it in Iraq and that
also i think is a story that even if you
believe that the specifics now are
related to Isis the bigger picture of
having to go in to solve problems that
we
a sort of in a certain sort of way
allowed to exist is not new to American
foreign policy not at all I mean we've
never left Afghanistan we never really
left Iraq my bigger concern at this
point as our in Syria and Libya which is
two places that we never actually
declared war on and that Congress had no
say and us going into I also don't think
it's a coincidence that both of those
wars were launched in August because
August is when Congress is on vacation
so it's very easy for the executive
branch to go in there and bomb and know
that their check and balance the
Congress is not there to do anything
about it so that's I think that's not a
coincidence and I also i just don't
really believe that this is all about
Isis because just like you said we went
into Libya not because of Isis but
because we wanted to regime change we
wanted to get rid of the government of
Moammar Gadhafi and one thing that is
not being reported by anyone is that
like I said Isis's numbers were going
down and so there had to be another
reason for us to go in there well
moammar gadhafi son has been held in a
Libyan prison ever since we regime
change and it turns out two weeks before
we started bombing he was released and
so now he has aligned with that
government that was elected by the
Libyan people they have their own
military they were attacking Isis and
his hometown is the city of cert which
is the city that we're bombing so this
is bigger than Isis and like you said it
does go back to those reasons we regime
change in the first place and you know
when something is working don't fix it
um I think the thing that broke here is
not Isis I think it's not moammar
gadhafi sat-sun CF getting out of prison
you mentioned one other aspect I want to
talk about which is that there was no
congressional vote on this action these
airstrikes were uh basically done under
the legal authority of the 2001
authorization for military force that
really was meant for the perpetrators of
911 al Qaeda to go after uh uh those
groups and it's been used mostly for
that but with every passing year that
same authorization of force is used to
create other uh offensives and what's
amazing to me is there's kind of a dub
alleged sword on the one hand you can
make a pretty good case that were pretty
far removed from that now and really
there should be a different legal
authority for these actions on the other
hand you can actually connect it to that
authorization of force insofar as much
as the instability we're now trying to
deal with is related to prior decisions
made under the exact same authorization
of force so as much as I'd like to say
it's crazy to still rely on that there
is a connection you can draw says
struggle to find the connection with
Libya I spent the last two weeks looking
into why we regime changed in 2011 and
it had nothing to do with 911 I also
reread the 2001 authorization for the
use of military force which all
Americans should do it's less than a
page and it says specifically it's to go
after the people that were involved in
planning and attacking us on 911 Moammar
Gadhafi was not one of them and no I get
that and maybe I stated just in order to
be clear what I mean is on the one hand
there's no doubt that it's being used
now for incursions that don't actually
have anything to do with the reason that
we have that authorization for military
force what is interesting and for me
this is not a justification but it's
more of something to think about that
the existence of Isis is in many ways
connected to the vacuum that was created
by decisions made in relation to that
original authorization for military
force it's not in any way of Defense of
what we're doing it's just sort of
something that I can't help but think
about whenever I realize how far we've
strayed from the original point of that
authorization yeah the the ball the
snowball that just rolls down the hill
and gets bigger and bigger and bigger
correct it's really what we've created
here because it was 911 and then we went
into Iraq on false pretenses and then
whoopsie Isis became a thing you're
right it's all connected it's just not a
justification the only thing I'm
concerned about at this point is that
Lindsey Graham who's a crazy senator
from South Carolina he authored an
authorization for the use of military
force that senator Mitch McConnell who's
the leader of the Senate he had it
skipped the entire committee process so
it's ready for a vote in the Senate so
if we're calling our congressmen and
encouraging them to do a new
authorization for the use of military
force we might end up with
Lindsey Graham version which is even
worse than the 911 version this one
really does authorize war anytime
anywhere against anyone and I know that
sounds extreme but it's true and so I'm
really concerned that our reaction to
this type of stuff is to be like hey we
need a new authorization we might want
to be careful wish for here because as
bad as the 911 one is the one they have
waiting in the wings this is gonna
authorize so much more than this one
even does and it doesn't seem to be
holding back the Obama administration at
all it's funny how on the one hand
Lindsey Graham is often the voice of
reason when it comes to the insanity of
Donald Trump and on the other hand much
less publicly of course uh he is he is
doing this same Lindsey Graham though
same guy and I know Lindsey Graham from
watching hearings I watch him in the
Senate Armed Services Committee all the
time where John McCain is the chairman
and that's where I really have concerns
about him I mean he I think he truly is
afraid of everything and so that's why
he feels and he acts he asked the
military commanders like wouldn't you
like to be able to bomb wherever you
feel is necessary at any time and have
it be open-ended like doesn't this sound
great to you and of course they said yes
but that's my concern with Lindsey
Graham I mean he he's definitely when
those people that tells you exactly what
he thinks but unfortunately when it
comes to matters of war he feels like
the executive branch whether it's
democrat or republican should be able to
kill people at any time it's it's
concerning in the last couple minutes we
have since you've been covering this in
in a variety of different ways now for
some time i'd be curious to get your
thoughts on what my view is right now
with regard to the fight against Isis
I've been saying for a while that I
don't think it is going to be difficult
to essentially eliminate all quote Isis
strongholds in Iraq Syria and to the
extent that they still exist in Libya
with in something like 18 to 24 months
however I think that it's going to be
far more difficult to really go after
these cells and these sort of more
isolated lone wolf but Isis inspired
types that we're seeing in Europe in the
United States etcetera presents a
completely different challenge in
question where are you on on that idea
so I agree with that if Isis was
actually our goal but what I'm seeing in
these hearings is that you know the the
iraq-syria situation is kind of combined
now because they're trying to fight the
Caliphate in Iraq and Syria but when you
watch the hearings everyone from the
State Department and the Department
offense is still talking about regime
change they still want to get rid of
Bashir al-assad and in Libya like I said
Isis's numbers were going down
dramatically and quickly and so we
didn't have to go in there I honestly
think it's to stop the ganache Gaddafi
regime from coming back so if if our
goal was to actually stop these Isis
people which by the way how do we define
them but if that was our goal sure we
could pull that off but what I'm seeing
by watching Congress is that it's bigger
than that they're still trying to change
regimes and using Isis as an excuse
that's my biggest concern is that this
isn't really about Isis about other
things in Isis is the lie no doubt and
uh and we don't we won't get into this
today but Isis has also been a useful
prop for Russian involvement in the
region and that's something we've been
talking about for a while as well all
right Jenna briny host of the
Congressional dish podcast check it out
jen thanks as always for joining us
thanks for having me